you're sick away you have the most
unusual names here
oh my god hi my name is marianne buggs i
am native american i'm a registered
member of the caddo tribe from oklahoma
and i'm also cheyenne and rappo
my name is silas cleveland i'm from
lander wyoming i myself am eastern
shoshone i
am calder ness from kennebec south
dakota i'm bartness who's
death and i was raised on the lord rural
sioux tribe
indian reservation so you're also raised
i'm brandi lewis
i am enrolled member of the choctaw
nation of oklahoma
and today we're going to be reviewing
some native american characters in film
and tv
native american and indigenous
representation in film
is quite often inaccurate and the reason
for that
is that oftentimes the stories are being
told
by non-natives i grew up watching
westerns with my dad on tv
i'd say sometimes i'd say why are we
watching this movie again with these
people who aren't really
indian we called ourselves indian those
days and he'd say well maybe someday
we'll actually win
because we were always the ones that got
killed off or you know
worse things our houses are fine you
think that
only because you don't know any better i
don't think very many natives like
hearing these kind of things
there's so much we can teach you we've
improved the lives of savages all over
the world savages
not that you're a savage just my people
no
listen that's not what i meant let me
explain let go
no i'm not letting you leave
that dress kills me it's such a
disneyland sort of take
on the historical figure of pocahontas
savage is just a word you know
a term for people who are uncivilized
like me well when i say uncivilized
americans i'd say you are some of the
most civilized people have been for
centuries what you mean is
not like you for many years i resisted
watching the movie pocahontas just
because i knew
it was going to be a bad representation
i really kind of stay away from these
tags like i
i never really had our kids watch them
because they're not even close to
the truth yeah you know yeah
she's super hyper sexualized but i liked
when
she's you know reacted to him calling
her a savage because i think that's what
a lot of people think
still to this day pocahontas in reality
historically was a young girl she was
taken and forced
to marry john smith against her will and
it wasn't a beautiful love story
she had a lot of trauma in her life that
i when i read the story a long long time
ago
i really related to because i think a
lot of our people
are still to this day suffering from the
trauma they experienced
whether it's this generation or past
generations are you
even in north dakota they pronounce it
three different ways
he went here having a native american
track someone you're amazing i think
she's actually a great tracker too
she was yeah it's a really big deal when
you see native americans in film and
sacagawea being
part of my ancestries in my tribe that's
a pretty
big ordeal to me i was struck by her
outfit because that's the next thing i
look at is
i try to figure out what tribe they are
by looking at their dress
and it was very um non-native american
yeah it's just a stereotypical um
portrayal of her with the braids i bet a
lot of people haven't heard of sacagawea
before
and so at least it was educational from
that viewpoint i assume this is like
like a kids
movie technically you're a council
meeting crasher scene from twilight
the council leaders dad quill's grandpa
and
two clear water clearwater took over for
her good name died
venezuelan can you say quillians in the
beginning i don't know if that's a
tribe but maybe it is there's 570 plus
tribes in the united states so i don't
know all of them
shape-shifters this is a great example
of oral tradition which is a very
very important part of native american
history
stories being passed down for
generations and now i see at the end
they're near water and she's wearing the
older lady is wearing
shell earrings so it must be in the
pacific northwest i'm guessing
actually overall i was really happy that
uh
there were so many native american
actors making money
i think they did a good job you know
showing to modern native americans they
dress like everybody else and not every
native has a
crazy name or anything you know they had
the seth clearwater i think it was on
there regular names there are many
traditional last names still but
not everybody's named like pocahontas or
something like that
are you really
i've heard of them as if if he hadn't
heard of that maybe he wouldn't
really be indian because i tell people
what my tribe is and kato isn't a
well-known tribe
and they say i've never heard of that as
as
i made it up can you be the peacemaker
the music i'm a boy
my name is omri great spirit can be a
child which mean i don't think the great
spirit
would be a white child especially how do
you know english
we know the english the english there's
stuff for us to fight the french for
them
i know that's true and i wonder how many
people watching this film actually
caught that
that was not at all what i expected it
was going to be about maybe in a cover i
think a lot of people don't realize
the accuracy of his comment that uh
native americans were employed
by the english to fight the french
that's really important for
people to know the accurate part of
history what i've experienced is
children
being told what their parents think
based on what they've seen in old
westerns
and i think this would give them an
alternate view
much closer to the truth of my people
that is really cool
that it's like some magical cupboard and
then he can he can kind of learn about
the tribe or like the past one day this
ranch is gonna be yours but i don't want
this ranch
what is going on who is this woman was
she adopted maybe
you are ungrateful and you don't deserve
this
well you're an indian giver how is
promising someone something then taking
it back
named after us i'm like confused because
why is she blonde
why does she not look one speck of
indian yesterday i saw you try to milk a
male buffalo
whatever mom it worked i put it in the
fridge
i mean there's it's actually kind of
funny
but elders are having a school
definitely playing into like
i would hope that the writers and the
producers of this
particular show would talk to the two
native american actors that they
employed to do this i feel like it's
meant to be joking about the stereotypes
actually i guess i would want non-native
people to know that you know a lot of
times
the stereotypes that you see are so
like overt it's laughable i
think that the majority of the clips
that i saw
had inaccuracies as far as portraying
native american people
you know i'd love to see hollywood
giving more opportunities out there to
different native americans
i really just think it's it's it's
important to have
native people telling native stories and
i think the more realistic and the more
the more natives that they bring on to
these sort of
movie you know they're just there's so
many interesting things with the indian
tribes i think a lot of people would
really enjoy to watch if one of those
movies made you want to learn more about
native american tribes you should
research which ones are in your state
i hope that you the audience don't get
all of your ideas about native american
people from
tv and and movies that you
are encouraged to explore native
american
accuracies um there's a lot of books out
there are powwows that happen in every
major city and if you want to
learn more about actual native people
talk to them